Hey, hello world it Saroj.
Welcome to my live stream.
My other live stream a software
was, you know, technical issues.
So that's not heavy.
But anyway,
in this video we're going to perform
some quantum machine learning,
some very exciting stuff.
There's some people in the,
in the other life room that
need the link to this video.
So I'm going to go ahead and post it in
that India video description to that.
Okay. Um, so anyway,
so we're going to talk about quantum
machine learning in this video.
I've got two great. Um, I've got some
great topics to cover. There's a lot,
actually, there's, there's so
much to cover here. Um, but uh,
let me just pack that in nature.
Everybody's coming into this live
stream that we have going on right now.
Everybody's in. Okay, cool. Just slight
little technical error. It happens.
And now we've got people in here,
right? 280 viewers in your, okay.
So let's just get right into this code.
Um, Oh, before we get into the code,
I just want to say something.
I want to say that D-Wave Wade went
ahead and invited me to their office and
then Vancouver and it was a,
it was a pretty cool experience and a
seeing is believing. So I can, I can see,
I can definitely say that I saw a
quantum computer myself in person.
I met some really cool people
there and I, I just, I'm,
I'm a believer now I'm a believer in
the power of quantum computing to help
accelerate machine
learning applications and,
and to help us create new
types of algorithms that we
did not think are possible.
So in this,
in this video I'm going to
go over quantum mechanics,
quantum computing,
including the hardware and how
cubits work in terms of the hardware.
And then we're going to demo some
machine learning applications. Okay.
So I'm going to go ahead and screen share.
So unfortunately we might not be able
to see each other a while we do this,
but um, that's just how it goes. And I'll
hit, I'll be answering questions as well.
So let me go ahead and
move that out of the way.
And it looks like screen
sharing is working great.
So let's go right into this
a lecture we have here.
Okay, here's our lecture. Let me, let me
and make sure everybody's in this,
in this chat room. By the way,
we've got a lot of people who need to
be in here and I just want to make sure
that the links are working. You know,
everything's working. All right, cool.
People are listening. There's
got 500 people watching this. Uh,
this, this thing right now. Okay? So,
okay.
Okay. So you guys can hear me,
right? Right. So here's, here's,
here's what we're going to do.
This I want to see, uh, the,
I want to see people qualities low,
right? Let me, let me make it better.
Let me make the quality just a little
bit better by making this bigger. And
hello from Brazil, right?
Everybody's there. Okay, so
here we go. With this, let's,
let's get right into this. Okay. So
first of what is quantum mechanics?
Quantum mechanics is
cc me, a, uh,
sprint. Hey, then that's just going to be
in the corner. So I'll be in the corner.
Okay, cool. All right. So you know,
whenever it works for now, whatever works.
Okay. So, um, what is quantum
mechanics? Quantum mechanics is,
uh, at the subatomic level
things or different, okay. Tldr,
things are different.
At the subatomic level,
mattered is quantized energy
is [inaudible]. Momentum
is quantized meaning.
There are some really strange
phenomenon happening at the,
at the subatomic level, at the level of
particles of electrons, things like that.
So the official definition is quantum
mechanics is the body of scientific laws
that describe the motion and
interaction of photons, electrons,
and other subatomic particles
that make up the universe. Okay?
So very exciting stuff. So if we
were to flip a coin, okay, so here,
here's an example. If we were
to flip a coin, in our reality,
we are used to one truth,
okay?
That coin either fall on heads
or he will fall on tails, right?
It's going to be either
one or the other and um,
make sure that I'm over here in
the, in the corner, okay? Right?
It's either going to be heads
where it's going to be tales.
And so we're used to one
truth in our reality.
We're used to one truth in our reality
and but at the quantum level,
there are multiple truths.
A coin can be in both heads and tails
at the same time. So in our reality,
when we flip a coin, okay,
so I'm, I'm demonstrate. We
flip a coin, we look at it,
we know that it's going to go up.
We know that it's going to go down.
We know that it's going to hit land
on heads or tails. There is one truth,
but at the sub atomic level,
at the, at the smallest,
at the smallest level of the universe,
the laws of physics behave differently.
There are multiple truths and we can prove
those multiple truths mathematically.
What do I mean? Let's assume
that I'm going to flip a
coin as a particle, so I'm,
I'm now Saroj at the subatomic level.
Now at the subatomic level,
when I flipped a coin
and I don't look at it,
that coin is going to eternally
just be flipping in midair.
It's going to be both heads
and tails at the same time.
These are both completely true.
At the same time,
a coin can be in both heads and tails.
A particle can be in two
different states at the same time.
These are both completely in 100% truth.
Okay?
And I don't say realities because
this is happening in our reality.
And so if I observed this
coin, then immediately it
will pick it heads or tails.
And when I say observe,
that doesn't mean a conscious
observer that any kind of measurement,
either human nonhuman machine,
any time that that coin is
measured by any device, anything,
then it will pick either heads or tails.
And while it's in the air,
it is going to be a probability of heads
and a probability of tails at the same
time,
say 70 and 30%.
So how do we describe this
kind of crazy behavior? Right?
This is wild. This is wild. Well,
it turns out we can describe this
behavior mathematically and this is what
quantum mechanics is all about. Okay? Let
me make sure everybody's following here.
Uh, rock. Wow, great. 737
people here. Great. So, um,
okay. So there was this experiment
called the double slit experiment.
And I'm going to answer some
questions after we get through this.
Before we start coding, I will
start coding by the way. So, uh,
there's this experiment called
the double slit experiments.
And how it works is you
take an electron beam gun,
so it's just beaming out light and it
goes through two slits and then it's going
to land on the screen. And what's
going to happen is when we do this,
we're going to see this number two
that's on the right here. Let me,
let me make this a lot bigger.
We're going to see this number two
image that's on the right here. So it's,
it's to be, we're going to be able to
observe what is called interference.
So two different waves through the,
through.
Both of those slits will interfere with
each other. And that's kind of weird,
right?
Because we would assume that either light
is made up of particles or it's made
up of waves. Well, it turns out
that light is both, actually,
it's both a particle and a wave.
And we can describe this mathematically
using what's called Schrodinger's
equation. Okay, how do we
describe the properties of light?
How do we describe this particle
wave duality that light is,
and this is happening
at the quantum level.
So Schrodinger's equation helps
describe this particle wave duality.
And in the red that is Schrodinger's
equation and it's actually based off of a
lot of different theories in physics.
What the what,
how do we compute kinetic energy,
potential energy, conservation of energy.
So there's actually a lot of theory
behind it and we're not going to describe
that right now,
but just so you know,
things behave differently
at the quantum level.
And so the reason I talked about this
example is that quantum computing,
quantum algorithms exploit three
features from quantum mechanics.
And those three features are
number one super position.
Remember when I talked about the coin
flipping and then just being in mid air
and being both heads and tails?
That's called superposition in mid air
a coin to be in both heads and tails at
the same time. That's super position. Um,
and here's a great image of that. I know
it's in French, but a cyber lock on job.
No, I love French. But this was
the best image I could find on,
on the idea of super position.
Now there's a second feature.
It's called interference. Now, don't
worry if none of this makes sense yet,
by the way, I just really want it to
describe quantum mechanics. Okay. I,
I just think it's so cool. It is so
cool. I don't think it is so cool.
So where were we?
So super position is the second feature,
right? So that's the first thing. You're,
the second feature is interference,
right?
So those waves and the
double split experiment,
when those waves collided with each other,
that's interference.
They overlapped and
canceled each other out.
And the third feature is entanglement.
Now this is,
this is kind of hard to even explain in
the context of classical mechanics or in
the context of anything that we know of,
right?
This is actually quite an interesting,
um,
this is quite an interesting phenomenon,
but Tldr,
two particles that are
entangled affect each other.
So if you observe a particle here,
it's going to affect the other.
And there is no amount
of distance that matters.
Like this could be across the universe
and to particles could be entangled
across the universe.
Okay?
So those are the features of quantum
mechanics that quantum computing, um,
utilizes or exploits.
So we know that a bit in classical
computing can either be one or zero.
And in quantum computing a bit
can be both at the same time.
A cubit is called a cubit. Now a lot of
us have heard the term cubits, right? We,
we've heard this term,
but what really is physically
what physically is a cubit, right?
So before we get into that,
a quantum computer is using humans to
supply information and communicate through
the system, okay? It can be an,
and so one really simple
way to demonstrate the
power of cubits is to think
about the example of me using a
thank you. So Liam, I appreciate that.
So an easy example is,
uh,
thinking about writing a
random x on a page, okay,
I'm just going to write an x on a page
in a book and I'm going to put it in a
library with a million other boats.
Now classically,
we'd have to sort through all
of those books to find the x.
But in a quantum computer,
accubid in super position
can be in multiple places
at once simultaneously so it
can analyze every page at the
same time and find x instantly.
Now that is a theoretical
example because why? Why?
Because cubits are a lot of fun.
Okay.
Unlike classical computers that
can be in a super imposed, a super,
super imposed state.
Now we are all used to classical,
uh, sea moss transistors.
These are silicon transistors.
CMOS stands for complimentary
metal oxide semiconductors.
And the way they encode and access
information is by using voltage, right?
So Zeros and ones.
What really represents zeroes and ones?
How do we create these states,
these binary states? Well,
the way we create them is by
using electricity, right? Voltage.
The voltage of a transistor
is addressed by a bus,
which is able to set into a
state of either zero or one.
That's how transistors work and taught
the computer you're using works,
but in a quantum machine, instead
of using that, they used a squid,
a superconducting quantum
interference device,
essentially a quantum transistor.
Now what does a quantum transistor
look like? Well, it's used,
it's instead of using silicon, it's
using a metal called neophobia. Okay.
The OPO, and this is a very, very
interesting Christine Metal, the opium,
I saw it myself actually at the way.
Very cool stuff.
But this metal is called Neovia.
And the the,
the really interesting property of
Neovia is that when we cool it down to
absolute near absolute zero temperatures,
like really freeze freeze this day,
then it's going to,
it's going to be become known as,
it's going to become a superconductor.
It starts to exhibit quantum
mechanical effects. What do I mean?
So here's an example of a cubit
built with this neodymium metal.
And so what happens is instead of
encoding states using electricity,
we are encoding states using
magnetism, which is, you know,
still based on the electricity,
right? Electromagnetism.
But the idea is that when we,
when we cool this Neovia metal,
it's going to create this magnetic wave
in either up or down direction of either
up or down.
And that's going to allow us to encode
a two states as tiny magnetic fields,
right? He's going to be plus
one. It could be minus one.
And that can be plus one and minus one
at the same time, which is super cool.
And so by adjusting a
control knob on our computer,
we can put all of these cubits
right, these little magnetic, um,
like magnetic coils coil is
not really the right word here.
These magnetic,
I'm super imposed a
particle cubits states,
we can put them all into a
state, which we can entanglement,
right?
We can entangle them.
So what happens when we take a single
cubit and we try to couple them with other
cubits so that we can have a more powerful
quantum computer? How do we do that?
So here's what it looks like.
So in this,
in this image we are seeing these
scripts, these gold strips, these are,
these are cubits.
So there are eight cubits.
Your four by four and the blue dots
represent what are called couplers there
couplers for these cubits.
And what the couplers do is there may
come superconducting loops and they put
many elements together and they allow
these cubits to interact with each other,
right? The more Cubans we have, the the
fact the, the faster our computer is.
And in fact we see an exponential speedup
where n is the number of cubits. Um,
you know, it's, it is an exponential speed
up the more cubits that we add, right?
So it's a magnetic field going through
the superconductor and we are putting
currents on either end of what
are called Josephson junctions,
which allow for this magnetic
field to be created. Um,
this quantum mechanical field that can
represent two states at the same time
when it's cooled. And so the really
interesting bit about the Qp, you,
the quantum processing unit, is that
there are no large areas of memory.
We're used to CPU, we're used
to von Neumann architecture,
right? Where we have,
we have a processor and then we have
memory but in a quantum computer,
but the processor and the memory
are interpolated together.
So it is both processing data and
it's storing data at the same time.
In that way it is very similar to neurons
in the brain in that we can think of
Cubans as neurons that
both process data and um,
store store data as well.
And we can think of the
couplers as synopsis that
we're connecting these neurons
together.
Okay.
Okay. So super, super cool stuff here.
And who provides these computers? Well,
D-Wave obviously IBM,
Google,
Microsoft until a lot of big players are
working on this right now I'm hitting,
we're, we're going to start seeing a
lot of startups coming to this space,
which is why I am talking about
this because the time is now,
the time is now for those of you who
are hungry to build applications for the
world that are going to
solve real business problems.
The time to use quantum computing is now
to speed up existing machine learning
algorithms and create entirely new
classes of machine running algorithms that
did not exist before. And I'm going to
show you how to do that in this video.
Now, Dewayne has a lot of
patents. When I was there,
I literally saw a massive wall of patents,
uh, which is good for them, right?
You know, market share, um,
that's going to be good for them.
And then there are others and so they've
been building a stronger and a bigger
and a faster quantum computer
over the past couple of years. Um,
and so, so that, that, that's
what that space is like. Okay.
So here's the big question. Are they
faster than classical computers, right?
That is the big question
that we want to answer here.
Or are they faster than
classical computers?
Right?
I liked the way you guys think.
So the answer is for some problems.
Okay.
It's not like they are going to
completely replace conventional classical
computers,
but they will augment that.
They will augment them and they will think
of them as a six. Right? Think of them.
Has specially special devices
for a specific set of problems,
just like we think of CPU at or CPS
or a processing sequential data.
GPS are great and matrix operations,
uh,
quantum computers or great at
solving problems that
involve quantum data.
So anything involving a simulation where
you're trying to simulate our universe
because our universe operates using
both classical and quantum mechanics.
And that is in fact why Richard Fiman
wrote the paper on this, you know,
a couple of decades ago because he
envisioned a computer that could simulate
reality perfectly.
And the only way to do that,
it's use a quantum computer so that we
can simulate quantum mechanics and um,
right. So, so there's that. We can use it
to speed up machine learning algorithms.
We'll get into that in a second.
Um,
and so it's actually really hard to
build a quantum computer as well. Um,
we can think of this whole process
of quantum computing as a process of
engineering.
The pattern of a complex set of waves,
these electromagnetic waves in hopes of
channeling that flow towards the correct
answer. So in machine learning, we are
used to defining an objective function,
right?
We've got this objective function,
we're gonna and then we're going to learn
a function with a proper coefficients
using some optimization scheme,
like say gradient descent to get
solved that objective. And you know,
we might have some constraints.
Now in the quantum world when we
are doing quantum machine learning,
that same idea is there of
us to finding an objective.
But there is much more of an emphasis
on defining what the constraints of the
problem are because it's like defining
the constraints of the problem.
And then just like letting these waves
interact in ways that we have no idea how
they're gonna interact and then hopefully
it's going to come up with a solution
to our problem. Right? We don't know
what that answer is going to be,
but we can define the constraints
of the problem, you know,
threshold values and you know,
lower balance, things like that.
And then we'll converge on the function.
Okay. And that's kind of hazy. We'll get,
we'll get more detailed in a second here.
But there's another problem with
comp Quanta computers is that they,
they fall into this decoherence
coherence state, right? Uh, where, uh,
basically there are leaks there,
these quantum leaks,
and it's really hard to keep them all
in this coherent state where they're
entangled, they're working together and
they're, they're used to compute things.
You know, it's, it's, it's the mixture
of variables involved in cooling and,
you know,
things like that.
So it's hard and a lot of times it's
not worth the effort to build a quantum
computer when you could just
solve a problem. Classically.
So what are the applications
of quantum computing now? Uh,
there are a lot,
these are being used in production,
so from cryptography to medicine
to obviously machine learning,
searching for, you know, in big datasets.
And I've actually got a giant list here
for different industries and how quantum
computing can be used to solve
problems in these industries.
So definitely check this out. You know,
a lot of different industries here.
Um,
and so even Dewayne,
they've got this great a landing page
that shows their clients and what they're
using for using quantum computing. So
from Volkswagen, Booz Allen, you know,
recruiting and NASA is using
it. Um, material simulation.
Like I said, I'm like five minute
envisioned, Monte Carlo simulations,
things like that.
Okay.
And so we can think of this stage that
quantum peers are at now at the same
stage at classical computers
were in the 50s, right?
Still very introductory technology.
We have some basic idea of how these,
how this hardware works. But think
about classical computing. Do you,
you don't think that the people designing
the CPU in the 50s had a idea that
apps like Facebook and you know, et
Cetera, but the apps that we all use,
um, would actually exist.
It's such a, it's so,
it's so far off from the
original idea of a, you know,
okay.
Uh, about the hardware. So
here's, here's the real,
here's the real question.
How can it be used for machine learning?
So when I was there at the wave,
yeah,
when I was there at the
wave, I was very, um,
happy with, uh, the, the, the team.
They answered a lot of my questions,
a bunch of quantum scientists.
We all sat in a huge circle and just,
I was asking them
questions left and right.
And this is such an exciting
field of study of research.
Quantum computing is such an exciting
field because there's so much to discover
still. But there are four known ways
that it can be used for machine learning,
including optimization,
sampling, colonel evaluation.
And of course, you know,
gleefully we, we, we,
we look at this and think,
Oh yes, linear Algebra. Why,
what did your own networks
use it use matrix operations.
What speeds up matrix operations? GPU,
why? Because they do them in parallel.
Could we speed them up even more using
quantum computers? I definitely think so.
I definitely think so.
And in fact we're going to look at
a paper in a second that does that.
So they will speed up some existing
algorithms and enable a new type of
algorithm as well.
Okay,
so some images and so let's
look at the leap, right?
So let's look at their software that,
this is what they demoed to me
in Vancouver when I was there.
So if you go to the dashboard here,
they've got some, they've got some demos,
they've got to an STK installed, they've
got a QP you dashboard. And uh, we've, uh,
we've got one hour of Cupe you time,
which doesn't seem like a lot,
but if you think about how
fast a quantum computer is,
you can compute a lot of things in
milliseconds so that that hour is actually
quite a lot for a three tier, right?
This is free for all developers to use.
Now here is the coolest thing here. And
then here's where they really got me. Um,
there are Jupiter notebooks in the
browser and we can compile these quantum
algorithms in the browser. So let's,
let's look at a demo here. Um, first,
and this is called
social network analysis.
And then we'll look at the code and I
will, I will myself as well. Okay. So,
okay,
let's look at this optimization
problem here. Okay.
So this is an example of social
network from Romeo and Juliet. Okay.
So we all know the story
of Romeo and Juliet,
two star crossed lovers from different
families that these families were enemies.
But then they fell in love. And so there
was that new connection that was forged.
Right?
Okay. Let me move this out
of the way so that our great,
oh my God. Move, move, move,
move on. Sometimes you just got,
there we go. Oh, show to continue. Okay.
So at the sort of the story,
where are we at?
The start at the store and there
was a river that, that, that,
that cuts that divide these
two communities, right? Um,
there's a river that divides these two
communities and they all are connected
with each other and then they have um,
connections across the river
that are negative, right?
These are enemy connections,
but between each other they have friend
connections and then all of a sudden
Romeo and Juliet Fall in love and a new
connection is formed in this breath is
social graph. And this leads to
instability or imbalance in the network,
right?
Because what ideally,
we want there to be no
connection between both groups.
We want them a balanced network in this
case would be one where there are no
positive connections between the families.
So how do we rebalance this?
So the way we would do this
kind of quantum computer
is we would set the degree
to which two variables agree and
that's the cubits coupling strength,
strength and the degree to which a
variable tend to a particular outcome.
And that is the body.
And we're going to look at this
programmatically in a second,
but basically we can rearrange that rap.
So such that in a way that uh,
there is no enemy connection across the
river and the graph is in fact balanced
again, and we can use a
quantum algorithm to do this.
Okay. So you know, this,
this applies to, you know,
same exact thing is happening here with
this series and extremist thing and we
hit run and then it's, it computed
this structural imbalance problem.
And so what better way to demo how
this works then to look at code.
So if we go to developer tools here,
they have, or learning in docs,
Jupiter notebooks in the browser that
we can just start looking at right now.
That's,
let's check this out.
Beautiful. The colonel's
ready. Great. Good. Okay,
here's the kernel. So what are we
doing here? So let's just compile this.
So here's this toy example.
Nothing quantum is happening here.
And this like little,
I mean make this big.
Okay.
I think quantum is happening here.
Okay. All that's happening here,
it's bigger
is
we are building this network graph,
right?
We are building a network graph and um,
there is a hostile relationship set up,
hostile relationships and instead of
friendly relationships, that's it.
And then we can initialize a solver.
Okay.
And the solver hall explained
what the solver is doing here.
MMM.
And then we'll take that solver and
we'll use it to sample from the possible
outcomes.
Okay.
So we have the solver and
it's going through solve
that problem by sampling from
the set of possible outcomes.
And when we perform that,
it's going to show us the
frustrated relationships and
then rebalance the graph.
And we can even visualize that
right here.
Okay. So it, it rebalanced the
graph. We didn't see how it works.
You might be wondering.
We did see it worked,
but we didn't get to see this like little
visualization thing because a million
things go wrong in demos guys. But the,
but the point is that we just come,
we just computed I quantum algorithm in
the browser and now I'm going to code it
myself. So don't worry if
you don't understand what
the solver itself is doing.
I'm going to code that myself now and
then we're going to look at what the
solvers are. Also. Let
me answer some questions.
I haven't been answering
questions mad fast, right.
What are the questions here? Uh,
the questions are, uh, numerous,
any questions? So SGD Oh, great question.
So STD will be useless with
quantum ml. No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Gradient descent is not going
anywhere for the time being. Um,
but we can think as the analog of gray
dissent in the quantum world as simulated
annealing. Well, that's
simulated annealing,
quantum annealing because
quantum annealing is all
about energy minimization,
right?
We were trying to minimize some energy
and a system and simulated annealing is
used a lot by physicists to try to
minimize the energy in a system.
Quantum annealing is the analog of
that, um, to the classical world.
It's also the analog too.
It also the analog to,
um,
grainy the scent in the quantum world
because gradient descent is gradient
descent, is trying to optimize, um,
a landscape and it always
optimize it for the local minimum,
right?
The local minimum.
But what simulated annealing does is it
optimizes for the global minimum things
that Sdg Sgd stochastic gradient
descent cannot necessarily reach.
Uh, so there is hope, right?
Because a global funding,
the global minimum is better than
finding a local minimum. Now,
gradient descent has a bunch of
right, exactly. In Gym. So, so there
are a bunch of trips into the cast,
the grading dissent to try to improve
its, uh, its abilities to optimize,
right momentum. Adam, there's a bunch of
techniques and try to get it over the,
the giant hill that it has to go over.
Um, so yes, um, there is an analog,
it's called simulated annealing and there
is a lot of research in that direction.
Okay. So let me answer one more question
then. We're going against some math.
How can we learn ml in GPU?
So it turns out,
check this out, check this out. I'm
going to blow your mind. Second,
kick up this website, quadrant. Dot.
Ai Deep learning with a lot less data.
What,
what, what, what the,
what is this is a Dewayne business.
Okay. The power of generative learning.
You have my attention. You have
our attention. What is generative?
They've got a little demo here in
tensorflow. Okay. Okay. And the thing is,
I've already looked at this by the way,
I'm just being theatrical
here so it's not using,
I don't think I look at the code here.
It's not add download it.
It's not using a QP.
You correct me if I'm wrong guys,
but it's not using the QP you here,
it's um,
using this probabilistic distribution
algorithm instead of the quantum machine,
but it's a step in that direction
of using the QP you, um,
very exciting stuff. I, I met with the
machine learning team when I was there.
Very, very exciting stuff
is happening right now.
Specifically with Boltzmann machines
with sampling, right sampling,
Gibbs sampling specifically.
I met with a scientist working on taking
variational auto encoders and improving
their generative abilities
using quantum algorithms.
And, um, there were,
I met another scientist that was working
on an algorithm that decides which chip
to use and when to use it between a CPU,
Gpu,
Qq and other assets,
right.
That want me to be perfect low level
algorithm where you have this high level
model that you define and then
that's a low level. It's like, oh,
I'll use a coupon for this, for
this. And there's that. Right.
That would be all right. Cool. So,
um, yeah. Anyway, so that's that.
Make sure everybody's onboard here.
Great. And coding on now. Okay.
So you know,
I thought when I was going to do this
livestream that I would just be coding out
four different examples, right? One for
colonel evaluation, one for optimization,
one for sampling. Well, it turns out
that to even code a single example,
there's so much context that I have
to, you know, both learn and to convey.
And so I'm going to code, I'm going to
try to coat two examples, but we'll see.
For Time's sake. I might just,
I might just go with one.
And for simplicity's sake,
because there's a lot of, there
is so much theory here. Seriously,
I have never come upon
any subfield of AI that I,
I've never seen such amazing,
exciting possibilities and literature.
Okay.
There's a lot. There's a lot.
That's all. I mean, the rabbit goal,
the rabbit hole goes so deep. I
mean, check this out. Check this out.
Let me show you this paper. I was just
reading actually before this stream,
check out this paper that I
was just reading. It's called,
it's literally called
quantum machine learning.
It was published a couple months ago.
Um,
huge collaboration between a lot of
people. Beautiful. Um, introduction.
I mean they start off with um,
like human nature and told me and
Copernicus and then get into Hockfield
networks in Boltzmann machines.
So very cool stuff. But, but,
but check this out. By the way,
here's something that's very cool.
Are already measuring the speed ups
of these machine learning algorithms.
Quantum reinforcement learning, right? So
this is a part of move 37. So this is a,
here's your, here's our, our El
elements here. Um, and in general,
this is just good for reinforcement
learning engineers for and researchers and
everybody, right? Because quantum
can be applied to all sub deals,
or I believe,
and here's where the belief comes in.
I think that there is a
possibility to speed up many,
not all. I mean, I think
all has been disproven. You,
you can't speed up everything
in machine learning,
but there is a huge possibility space
and I believe that and we'll see as we
learn more. But look, look at this.
There are clearly speedups here and
they've been denoted those speedups here,
right? Um, square root of n
speed ups. So for perceptrons,
those are neural networks and you
know, things like that. So very,
very exciting stuff. Alright,
so let's start coding here.
Let's start coding here. Okay,
so here's what we're going to do.
We're going to start coding and
what am I,
what am I going to do is I'm just going
to start coding and then talk about what
I'm doing. So there is this library
called Die Mod. Okay. So Die Mod.
Uh,
basically he wants us build models
that are suited for the quantum,
the quantum machine. Okay.
Uh, Die Mod. That's what that,
that's what diamond does.
And a sheriff Api for binary
quadratic samplers were,
we'll get into what that is in a second.
So let me just import the library.
Now let's define our
input data, right? We,
we have to have to input data and let
me make sure this goes away. All right,
let me just find our can data.
Okay.
So our first input data is going
to be called H. And so what age is,
is it is a binary variable.
H is a binary variable
and it's kind of value for
both zero and value for one.
What Jay will be is it's going to have
a single value for both zero and one at
the same time. So as you're in it, and
that value will be negative one point up.
So negative.
Now what is this?
So each represents our linear biases
and j represents our quadratic biases.
Now, now it's time to actually look
at what we're doing here. Okay?
So I just need to start coding something.
So this is called the easy model or
the, the icing. Actually I model.
Okay. Um, the icing model
identifies phase transitions.
So in physics, right, something is
either be solid, a liquid or a gas,
or in the right,
something is either a solid liquid or gas.
And how do we identify the transition
from one stays like a solid to a liquid or
a liquid to a gas, you know, et cetera.
And so the icing model represents this
as an objective function that we're going
to, that we see right here
expecting did we icing model does.
Okay. All right. So
that's the icing model.
And, uh, here's, here's what
everything defines here. So, um, this,
this [inaudible] looking thing,
it's, it's sigma notation.
And what we're saying is let's
take the sum of all of the, uh,
of all of the variables that
are a part of our equation here,
where n is the number of
variables, um, and as,
as represents a spin. And so
what this does, but let, let's,
let's step back for a second here
for a second. What this model is,
there is a lot of physical systems
that we could want a model, right?
So Electron from individual electrons,
the collisions of entire galaxies, right?
So, uh, good models can
represent, are very generalizable.
They can represent the
collision of galaxies and
collisions at the subway on my
level. And that's why a IC model is
a good model. It can represent a lot.
This model
was proposed by a guy named Ernst icing
and it's used to represent that phase
transition,
right?
So variables represent spin up or spin
down states that correspond to plus one
or minus one values. These
are, these are magnetic,
these are a result of the
electromagnetic activity, okay.
Up Two particles.
And so they,
it uses discreet variables to represent
the magnetic dipole movements of spin
states,
which are either plus one or minus one.
And the data which are just the spin
states are organized as a lattice so each
spin can interact with its neighbors.
And so this is this,
this equation here then then represents
the state of that phase transition.
And is,
it is a quantum mechanical process.
It is a process from quantum mechanics
because it's dealing with the subatomic
level. And so what we need to, what we've,
what we're, what we just wrote here,
this is quantum data,
right?
This represents quantum data because it's
dealing with phenomenon that occurs in
all reality based on quantum mechanics
at the subatomic level and it represents
a phase transition. So, um,
this is our objective function
and what we want is for,
okay,
there are to be a UN, an
equilibrium here, all of our,
of our spin states so that we,
we reach this objective function of,
of upstate and downstate, some magnetic
up and down states at the same time,
right?
Simultaneously.
And so the way we're going to do that
is we're going to construct this, uh,
missing icing model. And we can
call this a binary quadratic model.
Is it binary quadratic model,
but using the dime odd libraries,
there are different types of
binary quadratic models. In fact,
this is a superclass of
icing. We can also create, um,
a Cubo model is different, kind of not
going to talk about today. Like I said,
there's so much happening here to,
once we define our model,
we can then sample from that model.
So remember a quantum algorithm,
ports sample from a
space of possibilities.
Okay.
And we can sample from that model. It's
like that. And that's, that's it. We've,
that we've computed our quantum,
um,
result that's going to satisfy
this binary quadratic model,
which is an icing model.
And then we can pronounce it what we've,
you look what we've,
um,
approximated and seeing
what's in the response data.
And I'm going to say, uh, this is
our sample. We have our energy,
right?
And we're going to print out
those samples and those energies.
Right,
right.
All right. Let's see what happens
here in Dalton Syntax where,
Oh four I'm from.
Okay.
Um,
right. Oh, this has to be print cs.
Okay.
All right, cool. So what does it,
is it simultaneously computed
all the possible, um,
states that it could be in
those coefficients and it
found a what they are and
then we're printing them all
out at the same time. So this,
this essentially we are simulating
this quantum mechanical system that
represents a phase transition, uh,
particles from a solid to liquid,
or I look at your gas,
et Cetera. And this can,
this has proven to be faster,
um,
faster computer using quantum
algorithms over a classical algorithms.
Now optimization in general, we'd like,
we find that Romeo and Juliet problem.
It's a, it's a, it's a big
thing, right? In general. Um,
right. So, um, anyway,
right as a lot of people.
So there's that. Um, and
there's also sampling, right?
So these quantum computers
can be understood as samplers
and prepare a special
class of distributions
and
run. So Gibbs sampling,
things like that. Um,
want to make sure these people are not,
are in the right place.
There are a hundred people waiting here.
That's a, whoa, there's 40 people. Okay,
good.
I'm gear
wrong link.
Come to this one.
All right. Back to this.
Okay. So I'm sampling,
it's another example.
I'd like,
there's so much give sampling variational
audit encoders. Uh, you know, we,
sometimes we initialize our weights as
random when we shouldn't. Um, there,
there are better ways of initializing
our weights for our neural network and
then random, better than
random. And I'm right.
So there's a lot of potential
here for sampling. Now.
Um, there's colonel evaluation,
there's the satisfiability problem,
uh, to sad problem, which
is an NP complete problem.
There is way too much for the single
stream. There's so much theory.
I don't want to overload your guys here.
How are you guys feeling?
There's so much.
I still have so much to learn as well.
Like I am totally a student of quantum
machine learning and I see a lot of a
potential there. So like, so,
uh, colonel evaluation, right?
So in machine learning there are
kernel methods, um, where we are,
we have some high dimensional,
uh,
data and we want to separate
it by a hyperplane, right?
So for classification for example, and
we can use the kernel method to, um,
convert that high dimensional data to
lower dimensional data so we can then
visualize it and have the
hyperlink hyperplane go through.
So I support vector machines
are a good example of that. Uh,
but there's also other examples as well.
Um,
and we can use a quantum algorithms
to estimate certain kernels.
One, they're difficult to
compete classically in.
The last thing here is linear Algebra.
Now this is really,
I think this is going to blow the,
this is going to blow the
lid off of everything.
Like if we can really get these quantum
computers to operate as neural networks,
you know,
if we can interpret the Matrix,
ascribing a quantum gates as a
linear layer in a neural network,
we can visualize how the Gatewood connect
inputs and outputs. And this is a very,
very exciting area of research. And,
uh, that's, that's in the future, right?
That there's so much theory there.
Okay.
So it's overwhelming isn't it?
It's a lot of stuff. More physics,
right? I mean, clearly, clearly. So, um,
you know what, I'm just gonna stop there.
I don't want to overwhelm you guys.
There's a here and, and you know,
if you want to see me talk about more
quantum machine learning stuff, um,
definitely tweetdeck needs, we had
D-Wave. Um, and we'll, we'll get,
we'll get something set up.
Maybe we'll do a full course on
this so that that's for later.
We're still working on move 37 right
now. And, um, we have a lot of,
of work to do at school, the ids, um,
everything's always going to be free.
All my education will always be free.
Don't, don't even worry about that. Um,
but it's a super exciting time and I'm,
I'm glad to,
I'm glad that you guys are here. I'm, I'm,
I'm excited to continue with this, uh, uh,
this stuff and uh, yeah,
that's it, that, that's, uh,
that's it for this live stream.
Thank you guys. Thank you
guys for being here. Okay,
so I'm going to go ahead and end
this live stream. Thanks. Karsten.
I'm going to end this live stream.
Thank you guys for coming and for now,
I've got to go, um, work
on some curriculum stuff,
so thanks for watching. All right, let's
love you too. Love you guys. Okay.